what have you learned from your time
with andrew what stuff have you taken
away from his work and the time that
you've spent together
man
um
first off he's just a great guy and so
it's pretty cool when you see someone
online
and then when you meet him in person you
know like
this is just a
great person like he want he genuinely
wants to help people and he's super
interested and passionate in what he's
doing and i think that can really help
us as well and the modern education
system the way it's set up like
how many of us end up winding up doing
something it's not like
we're incredibly passionate about that
so seeing how passionate he is
having something that you look forward
to that you're really into
i can see that as a big component of
happiness like deep down he's a
he's a really happy person
compared to the average person that i
meet
he's also very very interested and
passionate about what he's doing he has
something to look forward to and so in
the time we had together
getting out
taking walks in the morning before you
have your cup of coffee i mean there's
too much to count but
really basic things that someone could
start doing to construct habits that
could lead to better things so it would
be if someone's just hearing of andrew
huberman it'd be better to to really
dive into his content but
what have you applied you've applied
you've applied the morning walk before
coffee sunlight in the eyes yeah any
other stuff yep
any other stuff from him yeah i mean i
would just say i would just say
a bit of renewed uh looking at my life
differently of my happiness is not just
a thing right now like um
that will just stay the same forever
that you you you make your happiness and
part of that is really having things
that you're interested in looking
forward to and chomping at creatively
and business-wise so we just enjoyed our
time together i wasn't like i wasn't
like grilling him i try to
i try to be like you know uh pretty
gentle
people and
i like to observe and then i usually
take away something pretty big based on
what i observe
um so
that's that's as far with with huberman
but we're buddies and we stay in touch
and i'm sure i'll learn a lot more you
can also observe the fact that he is
jacked out of his mind you don't see
this it doesn't come across on a
on his podcast but i bumped into him in
kuya which is the um sauna and ice bath
place that i love going to in austin um
yep have you been
no but i was right next to there at on
it's right next to me yep it's literally
next door dude when you're in town i got
it i have to take you i have to take you
to kuya
and uh so the door the door opens and
it's late on an evening time and the
front doors
face
the
west right so the sun's setting
uh and
the sun sort of bursts in through the
doors and it opens up and it's just this
[ __ ] gorilla stood like silhouetted
from behind he comes in he's like hey
we've been talking on instagram i was
like hey man how are you doing you know
you shake someone's hand and you do that
handshake where you shake the hand and
then you you put your other hand on the
floor dude it was like hitting the
outside of a shed
like what the [ __ ] andrew what are you
built of what's what's wrong with you uh
but yeah he's he's jacked out of his
mind he's really really uh nice dude
he's coming on the show i can't wait to
bring him on and that's huge yeah he's
he's a big one we're going to do
something special for it as well i think
that's awesome but
yeah i just couldn't believe how
how big he is it really doesn't
uh show on camera
he really takes care of himself and i
think that's one of the things that
makes him great is that
you have you have the mind you have the
body and he's working both angles and
he's he's really living it he's not just
sitting off detached out of shape out of
touch so i mean
yeah he's he's jacked skin in the game i
think
yeah
skin in the game exactly what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace